most of the immune system is physically  located in your gut about 70 to 80  percent of it well the immune cells are  on one side they're on the inside part  of the net inside your body and your  trillions of microbes are on the outside  on the other side of the gut lining and  of course there's a thick mucous layer  also surrounding the gut microbes but it  is literally this hand and glove  relationship and there's constant  communication so the gut bacteria  actually guide that immune response  they're constantly sending signals to  the immune cells to tell them what to do  we know that fiber is a main ingredient  for creating a healthy microbiome fiber  and fermented food less than five  percent of Americans are getting the  recommended grains and greens Etc so if  your complement of gut bacteria are off  and you don't have a healthy microbiome  your immune system might not trigger  that release of virus slaying  capabilities